hallo wir haben unsere faz.net nutzer
aufgefordert uns fragen zur
amerikanischen wahl zu schicken
wir haben viele dutzende fragen bekommen
und wollen jetzt einige beantworten was
hat sich trump für seine zweite amtszeit
vorgenommen ist die erste frage und die
antwort ist gar nicht so ganz einfach
denn trumps versprechen lautet vor allem
ich mache da weiter ich bleibe einfach
trump so wie er mich kennt selbst nach
seiner krone erkrankung hat er da nicht
seine politik wirklich geändert er
verspricht ein impfstoff bis jahresende
er verspricht dass nächstes jahr der
alltag völlig zurück kehrt er sagt nur
nicht genau wie das gehen soll
es gibt auf seiner website inzwischen
eine liste mit sachen die er machen
möchte zum beispiel zehn millionen jobs
in zehn monaten zu schaffen er möchte
billigere medikamente für die leute und
billigere krankenversicherungen anbieten
aber er sagt nicht wie er das machen
will
er verspricht immer mehr konservative
richter zu ernennen damit abtreibung
schwer wird waffenrecht leicht wird und
zuletzt hatte auch wieder angefangen zu
sagen wir brauchen eine mauer und mexiko
wird sie bezahlen das kennen wir noch
von 2016
die frage lautet stehen sich die
amerikaner auch jenseits der wahl so
feindselig gegenüber und man spricht
tatsächlich von einem stammeskrieg der
stamm der demokraten gegen den stamm der
republikaner
das ist nicht so dass man im alltag in
amerika nur diese feindseligkeit erlebt
was aber auch daran liegt wenn ich
republikaner bin ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit sehr groß dass ich
irgendwo lebe wo fast alle anderen auch
republikaner sind und umgekehrt das
heißt die amerikaner kommen gar nicht
mehr so viel miteinander ins gespräch
haben nicht viel verbindendes von vielen
studien eine besonders krasse vor kurzem
hat ergeben dass 45 prozent aller
demokraten sagen sie wären sehr
unglücklich wenn ihr sohn oder ihre
tochter ein republikaner heiraten würde
umgekehrt ist das ähnlich und das zeigt
eben davon dass es wirklich eine große
unversöhnlichkeit gibt in dem land die
dann noch verschärft wird dadurch dass
die menschen ihre nachrichten aus
verschiedenen quellen bekommen und ganz
verschiedenen realitäten oder eben
alternativen fakten glauben
häufiger sind wir gefragt worden wie
kann es sein dass in einer demokratie
gar nicht unbedingt der kandidat gewählt
der am meisten stimmen bekommt in
amerika wird nicht derjenige unbedingt
präsident der im ganzen land am meisten
stimmen bekommen hat sondern der in
genug bundesstaaten gewonnen hat um eine
mehrheit im elektro college zu bekommen
alle wahlleute eines staates gehen immer
an den kandidaten der in dem jeweiligen
staat die mehrheit gewonnen hat dabei
ist es völlig egal ob ich hauchdünn
gewonnen habe oder ob ich an 70 80
prozent sieg errungen habe immer wieder
sind es die demokraten die in den
staaten mit vielen großstädten diese
sehr großem vorsprung erzielen zum
beispiel in kalifornien oder new york
aber davon haben sie nicht sie kriegen
dadurch nicht mehr wahlleute hillary
clinton hat vor vier jahren die
präsidentenwahl verloren obwohl sie fast
drei millionen stimmen im ganzen land
mehr bekommen hat immer wieder geht es
in den leser fragen um das wahlrecht und
auch um die frage warum ändert man es
nicht einfach das elektron college war
ein frucht von mühsamen verhandlungen am
ende des achtzehnten jahrhunderts und
heute sieht die realität völlig anders
aus insofern gibt es auch in amerika
viele stimmen die sagen lasst uns doch
ein anderes wahlrecht machen wo immer
derjenige präsident wird er am meisten
stimmen bekommt dafür müsste man
allerdings die verfassung ändern von
damals und dafür braucht man große
mehrheiten
das jetzige recht nützt aber strukturell
den republikanern solange sie die partei
sind die auf dem dünn besiedelten
flachen land besser punkten können haben
sie ein interesse daran dass das gewicht
der dicht besiedelten städte nicht
steigt denn das würde den demokraten
nützen und solange eine änderung nur
einer partei nützt wird es diese
mehrheit für eine reform nicht geben die
wahlumfragen sehen im moment ja sehr gut
für joe biden aus aber leser möchten
wissen kann man diesen umfragen trauen
2016 hielten die meisten leute einen
sieg für hillary clinton für sicher aber
es kam heraus die umfragen waren falsch
diesmal ist der vorsprung von joe biden
noch stabiler aber trotzdem besteht die
sorge zwar ist ein problem
damals repariert worden es wird jetzt
mehr darauf geachtet dass nicht zu viele
gut ausgebildete wähler an der umfrage
teilnehmen denn man weiß dass donald
trump vor allem die nicht so gut
ausgebildeten wähler erreicht es gibt
aber die frage ob nicht trotzdem zu
wenige trump wähler mitmachen bei den
umfragen denn immerhin führt trump seit
langer zeit eine harte kampagne gegen
fake news und institutionen und man muss
ja schon freiwillig mitmachen wenn das
umfrageinstitut anruft außerdem fällt
auf dass trump einen kleinen aber
beständigen vorsprung in den umfragen
hat wenn gefragt wird sind sie mit
seiner amtsführung zufrieden da hat er
bessere werte als wenn gefragt wird
werden sie ihn wählen
das ergibt nicht viel sinn und deshalb
ist es gut wenn man da skeptisch bleibt
ja das war der erste schwung antworten
aber wir haben noch sehr viel mehr
fragen von ihnen bekommen und wir werden
uns mühe geben in den nächsten wochen
bis zur wahl noch sehr viele davon zu
beantworten die finden jeden tag
interessante informationen auf unserer
sonderseite sie können unseren
newsletter abonnieren sie können
mittwochs in den podcast für deutschland
rein hören wo es immer um die wahl in
amerika geht bleiben sie dran ist bleibt
spannend